to weeks of negotiations the White House
and Republicans have agreed in principle
to raise the debt limit President Joe
Biden and house Speaker Kevin McCarthy
made the deal days before the U.S was
projected to default on its debt the
agreement increases the amount that the
government can borrow it also Cuts
federal spending the treasury had warned
the government could run out of money to
pay its bills if Congress didn't act by
June 5th
after weeks of negotiations we have come
to an agreement in principle we still
have a lot of work to do but I believe
this is an agreement in principle that's
worthy of the American people
it has historic reductions in spending
consequential reforms that will lift
people out of poverty into the workforce
reign in government overreach there are
no new taxes no new government programs
there's a lot more within the bill we
still have more work to do tonight to
finish all the writing of it
let's go live out of Washington DC Al
jazeera's Patty culhane is there of
course Paddy agreeing to raise the debt
limit is one thing getting it through
Congress is another entirely
getting anything through Congress these
days is entirely uh questionable really
and they really running are running up
against the deadline did you mention
June 5th just to put it in perspective
so the U.S Congress has passed the bills
and say spend this money but then when
they get to the point where they don't
have any more money to spend they have
to raise the debt ceiling if not they
say that they'll go over the fiscal
Clift economic economic economists say
that would be absolutely catastrophic
not just for the U.S economy but also
the global economy so now they say
they've breached a deal in principle and
we know that house Speaker Kevin
McCarthy and President Joe Biden are
going to speak in a couple of hours just
to make sure they can finalize the
language then what's going to happen is
the house gets three days to read it so
that takes the vote to Wednesday we're
already hearing members from the far
right of the party say they are going to
do everything they can to tank the deal
so that means they're going to have to
have a lot of Democrats get on board but
the progressives are really not happy
with this because it puts more work
requirements on things like food stamps
that provides food for the poorest
Americans so the far right and far left
are already voicing really big concerns
about that the can the focus is going to
be on those moderates the people in the
center if there are enough of them to
get it through the house then it goes to
the Senate and we're hearing from both
parties again on the fringes but that
they don't like this deal that they are
not going to vote for it and they're
going to have to get 60 votes so if they
lose Democrats even a handful they're
going to need more than a dozen
Republicans and all of this again is
coming up against the deadline they have
nine days to get it done nothing moves
through Congress fast at all and nine
days for something this important it's
going to be a tense few days that's for
sure I'll just hear us Paddy Calhoun
live in Washington many thanks Patty